cuatro años después de la firma de los
acuerdos de paz la jurisdicción especial
para la paz se acerca a las primeras
decisiones mundiales este jueves
mediante un comunicado desempolvaron uno
de los capítulos más trágicos de la
historia colombiana elevando a casi el
triple la cifra de falsos positivos del
país civiles asesinados por la fuerza
pública y hechos pasar por guerrilleros
por lo menos seis mil cuatrocientos dos
personas fueron muertas y legítimamente
para ser presentadas como bajas en
combate en todo el territorio nacional
entre el 2002 y el 2008 la anterior
cifra de la fiscalía se situaba en dos
mil 248 y comprendía a los años 1988 y
2014 sin embargo la sep se concentró en
los seis años que hubo más falsos
positivos y que suman el 78% del total
histórico unos sucesos que ocurrieron en
los años de mandato del ex presidente
álvaro uribe vélez quien atacó al
tribunal en un comunicado
nuevo atropello de lage por 'falsos
positivos'
pero este no fue el único evento de
justicia transicional del jueves puesto
que seis miembros del antiguo
secretariado de la guerrilla de las farc
asumieron responsabilidades en
secuestros y otros crímenes de guerra
así lo expresó en twitter el partido
común es el partido político de las farc
que recientemente cambió su nombre
nuestro actual insurgente siempre estuvo
inspirado en la necesidad de transformar
la sociedad pero también reconocemos que
se presentaron hechos y conductas
sancionables a la luz del derecho
internacional humanitario' la gp es un
tribunal de justicia transicional
encargado de juzgar los crímenes más
graves cometidos en más de 50 años de
conflicto en colombia su objetivo
encontrar verdad justicia reparación y
no repetición eso pese a los múltiples
obstáculos que enfrenta